E aí
[Música]
o Olá pessoal antes de qualquer coisa
deixa eu fazer uma coisa
e dá o primeiro passo imaginei que fosse
muito mais difícil quando recebi o
convite e as primeiras orientações está
aqui no evento
o e confesso que mesmo tendo experiência
e conversar com outros tipos de público
por medo comodidade talvez sei lá eu
quase desisti de estar aqui mas eu dei
meu primeiro passo e é sobre isso que a
gente vai conversar hoje
e eu acredito que você da plateia muitos
têm ou já tiveram uma boa ideia mas você
já refletiram sobre os porquês dessa boa
ideia nunca ter saído do imaginário
e foi medo comodidade usei o que eu sei
é que um dia meus irmãos e eu estávamos
exatamente Nesta mesma posição tínhamos
uma boa ideia e muita vontade de fazer
acontecer
e dali para frente nós temos apenas duas
opções primeira esquecer o sonho ficar
na inércia e esperar que alguém mudasse
o mundo por nós e a segunda dar o
primeiro passo agir suar a camisa e
concretizar o nosso sonho eu acho que eu
não preciso dizer para vocês Qual foi a
opção que a gente escolheu
Ah e dessa feliz opção nasceu um projeto
de inclusão sociocultural
eu acho que tem gente já tem creme sabe
que sonho foi esse que motivou esses
esse pessoal arregaçar as mangas e
começar a trabalhar bom
Olá eu sou de uma família de 5 filhos
essa família foi informada pela
professora Mercy e pelo seu Orlando
a fazer uma análise rápida por questões
econômicas uma professora de escola
pública e um motorista provavelmente
nunca teriam condições de dar acesso à
cultura e ou qualquer outra forma de
inclusão para cinco filhos entretanto lá
em casa na minha família todos os filhos
fizeram música participaram de peças de
teatro grupo de dança como esse agora
pouco
o e tiver uma vivência diferente só que
isso não foi instalar em casa acontecia
nos vizinhos acontecia no bairro
acontecer em todo o nosso município Rio
Santa Catarina daí vieram
algumas alguns questionamentos que se
tornaram recorrentes lá na reuniões da
família Araújo
é porque essa experiência não acontecia
da mesma forma em outros municípios em
outros estados no país inteiro porque e
a resposta mas não que encontramos a
fórmula mágica para ter acontecido
aquilo também não descobrimos mas dessas
conversas vieram sonhos vieram ideias
vieram projeto veio a vontade de querer
fazer diferente de replicar Aquela nossa
feliz vivência e fazer ensinando música
com que outras crianças e adolescentes
em todos os países tivesse essas sabor
experiência
bom então é
[Música]
e o que que precisou o primeiro passo
Oi e o primeiro passo
e o que precisa para o primeiro passo
nós precisamos inicialmente sair da zona
de conforto porque lá tudo é muito bom
mas nada nada acontece na sequência nós
tivemos que nos municiar como se fosse
uma guerra uma guerra do bem no iniciar
com conhecimento em música conhecimento
em gestão e conhecimento em programação
e por fim é nós tivemos que procurar
meios de Alcançar nossos objetivos
é você que tem gente aí que já tá
pensando tá mas ele aprendeu música e
daí música música não é grande coisa é
só um passatempo é um hobby é uma
distração bom se a música fosse só isso
já seria ótimo pois todos nós sabemos da
Necessidade que temos em ocupar o tempo
de nossas crianças e adolescentes com
atividades saudáveis
Ah se fosse só isso também a música
infelizmente ela não é é isso Estudos
comprovam que outras habilidades a gente
alcança com música memória raciocínio
lógico-matemático Ou seja a música ela
ela vai além ela ela ela é o melhor dos
Remédios sociais
se você já imaginaram Se pudéssemos
ofertar esse remédio para todas as
pessoas do mundo de uma forma simples e
barata
e eu acho que eu convenci vocês a
necessidade da música não é então
preparados para o trabalho já saímos da
nossa zona de conforto temos as nossas
armas para guerra nós optamos por Inovar
ao máximo para fazer para fazer a
execução desse projeto mas sempre
seguindo dois princípios
é o primeiro o da universalidade que
seria praticamente concentrar todos os
esforços para que todas as pessoas
pudessem ter acesso à educação musical
daí a nossa necessidade a nossa grande
vontade de fazer com que os nossos
cursos sempre fosse muito muito baixos O
Segundo o da simplicidade
o que nada mais é do que sempre fazia
uso de uma linguagem limpa pura e
prática que possibilitasse alcançar as
mais variadas faixas etárias e os mais
variados graus de instrução
E aí
no vídeo de todo esse movimento surgiu o
material de trabalho uma vez que nós
optamos por utilizar uma metodologia
muito simples de educação um método
fácil de educação e fazer o uso de
internet para tentar alcançar o coletivo
como eu falei desse material nós
iniciamos um projeto piloto que foi
chamado o projeto-piloto polifono que
inicialmente Ele alcançou e quase 40
alunos e veja como são as coisas
e não basta para se empreender com
sucesso Você tem o conhecimento técnico
tem conhecimento de mercado público alvo
Às vezes você precisa encontrar pessoas
chave para que isso dê certo e nós na
pode for não foi diferente nós tivemos a
participação da professora Rosana que
era uma pessoa professor de educação
artística que não tinha conhecimento
algum e música não sabia nada de música
muito provavelmente não sabia nem a
forma correta de segurar um instrumento
musical mas mesmo assim ela topou o
desafio Ah já ia me esquecendo de falar
a polifonia Ela também tem um dos
grandes propósitos que é disseminar o
autodidatismo da importância dessa
professora
a professora Rosana tua começamos a
rodar o nosso projeto piloto e em poucos
meses já tínhamos Algumas crianças lendo
partitura e desenvolvendo algumas peças
musicais
o projeto cresceu chegamos a quase 450
alunos esses 450 alunos participaram das
festividades de Natal tocando algumas
musiquinhas para a nossa cidade lá
e esse meio tempo nós resolvemos dar um
outro passo aqui também é bastante
importante para quem empreende nós
exploramos o nosso sonho nós podemos o
nosso projeto nós colocamos eles nas
testagens de empreendimentos inovadores
que foi a inscrição que a gente fez uma
interação e infelizmente saímos sagrados
aí o primeiro lugar aqui do Mato Grosso
e Nem tudo são flores Gente Nem tudo são
força como se vocês viram 2017 tava
lindo um projeto-piloto cada vez mais
relevante a nossa atuação no Brasil ela
ia ser ampliando temos premiação tava
tudo muito lindo mas mas como todo bom
projeto especialmente os inovadores a
gente não podia deixar de passar por
aquele momento banho de água fria
em seguida aquela sensação de no mato
sem cachorro Pois é daí para frente
parecia que tudo ia Ladeira abaixo o
nosso projeto piloto desandou as
premiações de promessas ficando só na
promessa
e o nosso caixa já amargurada um período
ali no vermelho Resumindo não compraram
nossa ideia
o mesmo com o eficiência do projeto você
nunca Tinha um custo irrisório e tinha
comprovação prática e teórica não
comprar a nossa ideia
G1
Tá mas e agora
e o que fazer
O que fazer com sonhos e me concretizado
a devolver o imaginário
eu esqueci tudo e fazer de conta que tu
não passou de uma aventura mesmo depois
de ter cativado aqueles quase 500 alunos
a resposta é não gente não dá para parar
agora esse sonho já não é mais nosso a
partir do momento que você concretiza
começa a concretizar Um Sonho passa-se a
sonhar junto por muitos o nosso caso nós
estávamos sonhando junto com aqueles
pequenos flautista que tiveram seu
primeiro contato com a música e que
agora queriam mais e mais e mais aulas
não dava para parar
é bom como tínhamos Os Preparados e
temos a exata noção do nosso modelo de
negócio sabemos que o nosso público-alvo
não se resume às escolas temos outros
públicos e como se diz lá no mundo das
startups nós resolvemos pivotar mudar a
direção o foco a forma de abordar o
nosso público e onde colocar os nossos
esforços Afinal agora representavam nos
algumas centenas de sonhadores
e a esses sonhadores nós mais tarde
começamos chamado de polifônicos são os
nossos queridos polifônicos onde essa
mudança que aconteceu logo logo duas 500
sonhadores nós chegamos em cinco mil
outras abordagens de Eragon e os nossos
números foram crescendo crescendo
crescendo tava tudo muito lindo
em 2020 chegou
me convide
a anemia
é só a rede social óbitos muitos olhos
né tristeza bastante tristeza e aí que a
gente pode fazer para ajudar a população
vamos fazer doação em dinheiro e ajudar
as instituições de saúde não não dá um
gente não tem caixa para isso vamos lá
para o hospital no ajudar os técnicos os
enfermeiros médicos não a gente não tem
capacidade para a gente não estudou para
isso já sei nós somos uma escola de
música online que tal encher os lares de
música ocupar o tempo dos nossos
clientes as nossas crianças nossos
adultos os adolescentes fazer com que
todo mundo aprenda a música que tá
deixando nossa população saudável
psicologicamente e reduzir esse período
de dois estão passando resposta foi sim
essas perguntas Foi sim então lançamos
uma mega promoção não não foi uma mega
promoção foi Mega doação de aulas de
E durante todo o período de pandemia e
assim nós tivemos a oportunidade de ver
instrumentos empoeirados saindo de
armários de garagens escondidos nos mais
variados lugares onde instrumento sendo
adquiridos e tudo isso para fazer música
em casa
o e parafraseando nosso querido Chaves
que Deus o tenha foi sem querer querendo
que acabamos participando do novo normal
e nos tornamos e acabou sendo essenciais
também pessoalmente essenciais para
aqueles amigos lá da terceira idade ou
da melhor idade como quero que além de
realizar um sonho de aprender a tocar um
instrumento musical sonho antigo eles
mandavam mensagens agradecendo a boa
companhia que fazíamos a eles nesse
período ruim esperando triste
eu acho que nesse momento é legal a
gente lembrar daquele ditado popular se
a vida te der limões
e faça uma limonada Pois é a Polly forno
fez uma limonada e pelo visto ela ficou
tão boa tão boa que chegamos logo logo
em 30 mil alunos
há 30 mil pessoas tomando da nossa
limonada
E agora me digam
e o que acontecesse lá atrás atrás nós
não pensamos essa barreira da inércia
não juntássemos força e vontade para dar
o primeiro passo que que aconteceria
que nada aconteceria nada
bom então você consegue perceber Qual é
o custo que se tem para você saber o que
vem depois do sonho do projeto da ideia
do permite experimentar coisas novas o
custo o curso sempre será a vencer os
seus medos assumir os riscos e dar o
primeiro passo
é Então que tal você dá uma chance para
o seu sonho
o seu sonho pode ser algo que alguém
pode estar precisando em algum lugar e
basta a você dar o primeiro passo nosso
caso
nós percebemos que o mundo precisava de
mais música e Agimos e o caso de vocês o
que que vocês querem mudar para melhor
vamos dar o primeiro passo
é muito obrigado a
E aí
[Música]